welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and doc ock alfred molina is
confirmed to appear
in the mcu spider-man 3 returning from
the toby maguire spider-man 2 back in
2004
now alongside tom holland peter parker
in an increasingly
bonkers crossover cast including doctor
strange and jamie foxx elektro back from
the amazing spider-man 2
and on top of that other sources are
reporting that andrew garfield
peter parker from the 2012 and 2014
amazing spider-man films
and kirsten dunst mary jane watson from
the earlier 2000s movies
are also appearing that same report says
emma stone gwen stacy from the two
garfield films is in talks to return
pregnancy permitting and the big daddy
toby maguire
remains in talks and then most recently
some
totally unconfirmed reports coming out
today that charlie cox daredevil is
going to appear in this movie as peter
parker's lawyer i'm gonna wait to get
too excited about that until some real
news sources confirm it as one should
always ask
gazing into the interdimensional void
well with doc ock that makes three
formerly separate spider-verses
confirmed to be
swept together in a vast web of life and
destiny but this time
with a fan favorite villain a guy who
played 500 with people
all while humming show tunes if i were a
wealthy
man fight effects way ahead of their
time
in a time once known as pizza
pizza time i'm not paying for those this
is all
undeniably great news it sounds like it
is all coming together
bringing back characters like this that
the franchise overwhelmingly loves as
opposed to one some have some mixed
feelings about
signals a more specific agenda by the
studio when it comes to staging this
follow-up to spider-man far from home a
follow-up that is coming in the year
folks
that agenda not another reboot that
fixes or retcons but an
mcu spider-verse event that celebrates
its own great history
essentially a spider end game i am gonna
explain what this news really means
and how it further crystallizes the
narrative and the look this third film
will probably have
and of course how the multiverse barfed
on itself to make this possible first
just a quick recap of everything we know
so far
spider-man 3 is in the midst of
production shooting in new york and in
atlanta including a set video of a high
wire stunt with peter and mj and a blue
screen set photo released by tom holland
with a hand poking in the side that we
have speculated it could be andrew
garfield's finger hole cuffs
ned actor jacob battalion read the
script and was shocked
no janie fox electro is confirmed to
join the cast returning from the amazing
spider-man 2 last seen when peter and
gwen use the power grid columns to max
out his control chip
and obliterate him into electrons
benedict cumberbatch dr
steven strange is also joining the cast
in a mentor capacity to peter bringing
in the sorcerer's supreme to this plot
leads us to believe some navigation
through portals and a drama within the
multiverse
especially since directing doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
is sam raimi himself who crafted the
original tobey maguire spider-man films
in the 2000s and it is from that series
that our new contribution marches onto
set
tevia style alfred molina dr otto
octavius from
raimi spider-man 2 a mentor to toby
peter whose brain got
fused to ai arms in a freak fusion
accident last seen drowning himself in
the river
to keep his new fusion experiment from
consuming the whole city
alfred molina was reportedly spotted by
onlookers last month
arriving on set to work on some stunt
choreography now this doc awk report
comes from the hollywood reporter who
broke many of the other spider-man 3
casting reports and this was widely
echoed by other legit sources
as of this taping the andrew garfield
christian dunce reports
and the toby maguire emma stone rumors
are being reported by collider's jeff
snyder we'll see if we get further
confirmation of that but
how will all of these characters appear
in a movie together
will there still be room for tom holland
in it afterwards and why
are they setting up this end game style
crossover but before we continue i've
been thinking about making some personal
changes lately and i wanted to start by
improving my self-care routine the
problem was i had no idea where to start
and then i found hawthorne thanks to
hawthorne for sponsoring this video by
the way popcorn is a premium tailored
personal care brand that is making it so
easy for guys to feel and smell your
best and you start with their quiz
they ask me things about like how bad
your bo is
or if you're worried about bags under
your eyes and then they recommend
products for me
like this body wash using this stuff has
made me smell and feel classy
sophisticated like a real adult it's
about time right
this particular one that they pick out
for me is the gentle and mild nourishing
sulfate free it kind of checks all the
boxes and when i come out of the shower
i feel like
a new man and underline the man there
underline
now if you want to upgrade your
self-care routine hawthorne is a fun and
convenient way to get
super high quality products tailored
specifically for your needs
author even takes the risk out of it by
giving you free shipping on your order
and returns
and if you don't like your products
they'll even retailer them for you based
on your feedback so do what i did
take hawthorne's quiz today and get
started on your personalized
self-care routine by going to
hawthorne.co
and using promo code new rockstars do
get 10 off your first purchase
that's h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e dot c-o
promo code new rockstars hawthorne.co
promo code new rockstars okay in the
past i have wondered with trepidation
that sony
might try to retcon all of the
spiderverses into
one combined shared history just because
jk simmons j jonah jameson really just
appeared in the mcu no explanation there
were reports that simmons wanted his
jamison far from home cameo to be a
totally different character but
sony really was insistent on him being
literally the same guy
so they ended up compromising by making
the character bald simmons joked
so j jonathan james had either lost his
hair in the last few years or he was
wearing a hair piece the whole time
i don't know you pick i did my best no
one's quite the base that sentences
now this appearance came 15 years after
that same character
when he was trying to name doc hawk for
the daily bugle shouted out a future
avenger
doctor strange that's pretty good but
it's taken
an insane shot call by sam raimi who
would later
go on to direct doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness which again
is coming just months after spider-man 3
in the mcu timeline
that line applied then that dr strange
already existed in that universe
actually strange does live at 177a
bleecker street not far from the listed
address of joe's pizza before that
sticker was ripped off and it was no
longer pizza time
cool this plus a few other random
details sony has worked in there like
bone stomach name appearing on a post
room far from home in the mcu
despite the fact that macho man randy
savage's wrestler character was created
uniquely for the sam raimi spider-man
film there are also reports that marvel
tried to put oscorp tower in its new
york city skyline in avengers but that
sony and colombia couldn't get back with
the approval in time there was also the
deleted scene of nick fury telling iron
man about
radioactive bug bites back in 2008 as if
gamma
accidents radioactive bug bites and
assorted mutants weren't enough
also spider-man homecoming spider-man
far from home have deliberately left
peter's backstory
untold hinted at with a few lines and
visuals like uncle ben's suitcase
so now with jamie fox electro alfred
molina dock and others returning
i think there is a valid concern that
sony could
try to retcon the universe so that all
three spider-mans
exist somehow in the same new york just
at different points in history
throughout 2002
through the present and then never cross
paths with the avengers until 2016
but a history that doctor strange was
part of though i guess known only as a
famous surgeon
not as a sorcerer because you know that
was 2004 yeah you see how this is
confusing it would be less of a flip and
more of a slop
the only way all of these cameos make
any sense
is if this third spider-man film opens
up to alternate realities in the
multiverse
each of these spider verses were
separate universes
that recent events in the mcu have
caused to cross over with each other
which is why doctor strange is really
the key to all of this
clearly the events of this film must be
linked to whatever sam raimi is cooking
up for multiverse madness a film
confirmed to feature scarlet witch wanda
maximoff after her arc in one division
therefore
these three titles represent acts 1
2 and 3 of a kind of multi-title
multiverse event avengers endgame really
laid the groundwork for all this
the ancient one warned bruce banner that
too many alterations with infinity
stones in the past
would result in various dark chaotic
futures for whatever branch timelines
got created as a result of that meddling
and yes while cap returned the six
infinity stones and mjolnir from the
points of the timelines in which they
were taken
a few messy branches did go unclipped
like one we know about for sure was
loki's he escaped with a stolen
tesseract in 2012
creating a whole new alternate reality
in which he is alive in this upcoming
loki series
and again that's just one like we can
also assume that younger thanos
departing the 2014 timeline and
end game to join the avengers and the
president left that 2014 timeline with
no thanos no gamora no nebula no black
order
no thanos fleet or army and i believe
that loki series which is still on
schedule to release
time during 2021 probably before
spider-man 3
is going to show how the avengers
meddling in endgame
created a chaotic array of intersecting
alternate realities
ones that previously existed all fine on
parallel vectors like a harp no
string ever touching the next one but
now all those strings are angled in
directions
crossing over each other creating
dangerously close collision points
now one division i suspect will be the
trigger that causes this
delicately tangled web to erupt with
various convergent events like it's
right on the cusp of touching but then
wanda freaks out and then it touches
wandavision could be our act one
inciting incident now it's too soon to
tell with any certainty but wanda's
reality warping powers are clearly on
display in the show and whatever dark
entity is manipulating her to think
vision is alive again because he
ain't will lead to a betrayal in wanda's
powers
bursting from that bubble of her pocket
reality
spilling all over the universe causing
all the timelines to collide with each
other
timeline 1999 to crash into
timeline 96283 and crash into timeline
120703 those aren't random numbers those
are the marvel designations for the
dimensions of the mcu
the rainy verse and the andrew garfield
universe respectively making one
division the trigger point is why these
reality collisions were not yet
happening in any serious way in
spider-man far from home which yeah was
set
after the timeline medley in the event
game we need another event between these
to really screw everything up that's
gonna be what wanovision is
though one could argue that jk simmons j
jonah jameson happening to exist in this
reality
is a kind of minor convergence itself my
recurring macro theory has been that far
from home's post-credit ending will lead
to peter fleeing
to the sanctum of sanctorum where he
will seek the help of doctor strange
which will lead to the sorcerer's
supreme saying but
wait kid what just happened with you and
that conspiracy theory's newsman was
just the beginning and then strange will
open a portal
and guide peter along a magical mystery
tour showing him
the whole web of life and destiny all
the different eventualities of
alternate spider-man's and how all of
these different realities are now
colliding with each other
chaotically thanks to wanda's panic
attack that is how we are getting jamie
fox electro from earth120703 and maybe
andrew garfield peter and emma stonewin
as well as alfred molina doc ock from
earth96283 maybe also christian does mj
and toby maguire peter too
doc ock is really the final piece of the
puzzle of the sinister six lineup that
sony has been assembling with their
various spumsy titles elektro and doc
ock would join vulture morbius living
vampire venom or
carnage and then maybe also michael
mando as scorpion from homecoming that's
six and there's even more weight in the
wings in case
not all of them are there in spider-man
3 these villains could
band together across realities kind of a
stranger's on a train deal
i'll kill your guy if you kill mine
targeting the peters of their home
realities and it's gonna be on doctor
strange and peter as kind of the doc and
marty who jump in here
to try to prevent all these horrible
fates from happening like in the way
that the avengers and end games time
heights which was based on back to the
future part two so back to the future is
a bunch of [ __ ]
they revisited famous mcu moments like
the battle of new york peter quill's
morag dance
asgard during dark worlds this
spider-man 3 event home worlds as the
working title in my head cannon could
feature tom holland peter fleeing the
authorities of his homeworld by joining
doctor strange venturing into the
spider-verse helping
save all these alternate peters against
foes like doc ock on a speedy nail train
for helping save alternate peter against
electro and the grid columns maybe
catching gwen stacy at the last second
before her head smacked against the
ground
this time tom holland on the l train
this time tom holland in the electrical
grid filling in the shoes of all these
alternate peters in these battles
now the news that it still sounds like
some of these cameos are still being
negotiated
sounds like not all of these what-if
callback scenes might be locked in the
script
or at least versions of those scenes
that include the other peter parker's
especially if they already started
shooting
but some of them especially
confrontations with these past villains
appear to be confirmed if jamie foxx and
alfred molina are in this movie
now it's just a question if they can get
other spider-man and their girlfriends
to show up in a cameo that shows their
faces and gives them lines as opposed to
other ways they can do it like using
archive footage to show them from afar
but at the end of the day folks you
don't cast
alfred molina jamie foxx andrew garfield
kirsten dunst emma stone
maybe tony maguire in a movie just to
have them play versions of their
characters that are completely
disconnected of what we saw before the
fact that it's the same actor
is intentional to the story the
nostalgia is what this is all about
that runaway train scene keeps getting
referenced by sony in all kinds of
spider properties
we're gonna see it again in this movie
but through a new set of eyes
i obviously have a lot of thoughts on
this specifically how it sets up act
three of this multiverse event the
climactic showdown in doctor strange and
the multiverse madness by that step of
my macro theory and how it ties the
x-men into the mcu
is coming in our upcoming season finale
of rogue theory in which i will pitch my
best theory of 2020
against our worthiest nerdiest pitchers
of the year in front of a supreme court
all-star panel mark your calendars it's
coming
christmas eve and yeah with all the
stuff we're going to be talking about
more in the coming weeks especially as
we are expected to get an official first
look for spider-man 3 from sony before
the end of 2020. until then
support this channel by checking out all
of our great merch options in
rockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me on instagram at eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe hit that
notification bell thank you for watching
and uh by the way doctor strange be sure
to knock on toby maguire's store before
you open a portal to his room
[Music]
you
[Music]